let's talk about what's going on with
Comcast I think we do have time for the
story Pat let's go to it let's do the
Comcast story many companies were honest
in the lead-up to the Trump tax ville
they admitted we're not going to hire
people because of the Trump tax cuts and
that makes sense
that's how hiring works you hire when
there's more demand for your product or
service anyway Trump and some of his
cronies have been saying hey the tax
cuts worked because right when the bill
passed this company or that company said
we're gonna be hiring and of course that
hiring was more than likely already
planned ahead of time based on demand
for the product or service of the
company but that's ok Trump still
decided to tout it as a win for his tax
plan it turns out we've now learned that
Comcast fired 500 people right before
Christmas despite claiming that the tax
cut plan was going to lead to the
creation of thousands of jobs if they
got that corporate tax cut because of
the obvious hypocrisy that is
illuminated here Comcast did everything
they could to keep the firing secret
they even forced the fired employees to
sign a nondisclosure agreement if they
wanted to get their severance pay Ars
Technica asked Comcast if you were
planning to create thousands of jobs
with the tax cut that was days from its
passage why would you need to fire 500
people as the tax cut was passing and
Comcast provided the following statement
where they said periodically we
reorganize groups of employees and
adjust our sales tactics and talent this
change in the Central Division is an
example of this practice and occurred in
the context of our adding hundreds of
frontline and sales employees all these
employees were offered generous
severance and an opportunity to apply
for other jobs at Comcast what Comcast
then did is very slick these firings
happened on December 15 and then on
December 20th they announced that
because of the tax cuts and the net
neutrality repeal they would be giving
$1,000 bonus
to more than a hundred thousand
employees plus they'd be investing 50
billion in infrastructure and they said
with these investments we expect to add
thousands of new and indirect jobs it
turns out as usual
that this is complete and utter BS
Comcast has been making investments of
this size already during net neutrality
during the Obama White House the
announcement is merely we're going to
keep doing the exact same thing we were
doing anyway because if you're Comcast
you need infrastructure you need to
constantly invest in your infrastructure
to make money to serve your business so
what's really at issue here is
automation Comcast said that the firings
are getting rid of a lot of salespeople
who were walking around neighborhoods
and going to apartment complexes to try
to sell Comcast services and that what's
happening is that a new direct sale
system is being put in place it will
require fewer humans and that's why they
got rid of these people so this in the
in the end is just like when Trump saved
those thousand jobs at carrier in
Indiana and the CEO or the VP said
something like oh that's great yeah
we'll use the money from the tax cut the
tax credit to restructure our factory to
eventually move in the direction of
automation I don't really blame the
companies these are publicly traded
companies in a system that rewards one
thing stock price increases obviously
what they're going to do when Trump
comes to them and says hey we're not
generating any more demand for your
product but we're going to lower the
rate at which you can take profits great
opportunity to start doing more
automation and replacing people with
machines or people with even fewer
people this is economy-wide and what it
proves to us is that tax policy needs to
take into account the realities of the
economy you're not going to get
companies to hire with a tax cut now you
weren't going to get companies to hire
with a tax cut before but what you are
going to see is more and more companies
choosing to automate with any extra
money that they have which over the long
term is actually going to increase
unemployment another big victory for
Trump that is it for today no voicemail
great bonus show coming up thanks for
joining us